Containers are ephemeral, your database isn't, that's what persistent volumes solve.
When a pod dies, its container file system is gone.
For databases, caches and stateful apps, you need storage that outlives any pod.
Kubernetes gives you two objects.
A persistent volume is the actual storage, provisioned by an admin or dynamically by
the cluster.
A persistent volume claim is your request for storage.
Kubernetes binds them one to one.
Your pod mounts the claim, it doesn't care what's behind it.
Two provisioning modes.
Static and admin pre-creates the PV.
Dynamic, a storage class auto provisions one when the PVC is created, that's the modern
way.
Pod dies, data stays, that's the contract.
PV claims it, PV holds it, storage class provides it.
Run the docs, Kubernetes, persistent volumes.